[Música]
nada sé en el mar cuando algo rosa tu
pierna
sientes un hormigueo y te das cuenta de
que te ha picado una medusa cómo pueden
estas hermosas criaturas gelatinosas
causar tanto dolor las medusas son
suaves porque son 95% agua y están
compuestas por una sustancia gelatinosa
translúcida llamada meso que a sus
cuerpos tan delicados están cargados de
miles de células venenosas urticantes
llamadas nidos hitos para defensa y
captura de presas incluso las medusas
bebé del tamaño de un borrador tienen la
capacidad de picar las medusas larvas
efe
parecen flores diminutas que laten en el
mar al crecer adquieren forma de
paraguas con una campana en la parte
superior y tentáculos que cuelgan de su
borde en el extremo inferior la especie
más grande de medusas la melena de león
llegan a tener tentáculos de hasta 40
metros más largos que una ballena azul
la mayoría de las células urticantes
están ubicadas en los tentáculos aunque
en algunas especies están presentes en
las campanas también el veneno se
inyecta por un nematodo sixto un
filamento hueco con forma de látigo se
encuentra enrollado bajo alta presión
osmótica cuando los estímulos mecánicos
o químicos activan un disparador externo
la tapa de la cápsula se abre y se
rellena de agua de mar esto provoca la
eyección de una púa microscópica que
penetra e inyecta veneno en su víctima
y la descarga de nematocistos se produce
en menos de una millonésima de segundo y
es uno de los procesos biomecánicos más
rápidos de la naturaleza los
nematocistos pueden envenenar incluso
después de la muerte de la medusa por
eso es importante eliminar los
tentáculos adheridos a la piel un
enjuague con vinagre por lo general
dejará inactivos a los nematocistos el
agua de mar también puede ayudar a
eliminar los nematocistos residuales
pero no uses agua dulce ya que cualquier
cambio en el equilibrio salino altera la
presión osmótica externa del nido citó y
hará que el nematocistos se active por
eso orinar en la zona afectada un
remedio popular común puede hacer más
mal que bien en función de la
composición de la orina la mayoría de
las picaduras de medusas son dolorosas
pero algunas pueden ser mortales
la medusa caja del indo-pacífico también
llamada avispa de mar libera veneno que
puede causar la contracción de los
músculos cardíacos y la muerte
fulminante en grandes dosis hay un
antídoto pero el veneno es de acción
rápida y por eso se necesita una
intervención médica inmediata
de la impresionante potencia de sus
tentáculos las medusas no son
invencibles sus células urticantes no
son rival para depredadores de piel
gruesa como la tortuga laúd y los peces
luna estos depredadores tienen
adaptaciones que impiden a las
resbaladizas medusas escapar luego de
ser engullidas espinas orientadas hacia
atrás en la boca y el esófago de la
tortuga y dientes recordados detrás de
las mejillas del pez luna incluso las
pequeñas larvas de langosta se aferran a
la campana de una medusa y dan un paseo
comiendo la gelatina mientras preservan
su propia energía para crecer los
pececitos ágiles usan a las medusas como
arrecifes móviles por protección
escondiéndose entre sus tentáculos sin
tocarlos los nude y bronquios o las
babosas de mar cubiertas de limo
protector pueden aprovechar las defensas
de la medusa comiéndose sus nidos y tos
y transfiriéndolos a sus tentáculos
especializados para un uso posterior
como armas contra sus propios
depredadores e incluso los humanos algún
día podríamos beneficiarnos de la
picadura de medusas los científicos
manipulan los nidos y tos para
suministrar fármacos en hemato sistos
que rara vez superan al 3% del tamaño de
una aguja de jeringa típica así que la
próxima vez que estés en el mar ten
cuidado pero también tómate un segundo
para admirar sus maravillas
desea ver más de 'dead en español haga
clic en suscribirse nunca sabe que
conocimientos lo están esperando
nunca